[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to our
debate today on a live in the universe
i'm catherine heymans i'm a professor of
astrophysics at the university of
edinburgh and i'm also the astronomer
royal for scotland um now once we saw
ourselves as unique and special in the
universe but no longer because today's
fashion is to proudly believe that we
are not special and far from alone in
the universe every few months we hear
another story about the potential for
life on mars or titan most recently
pluto yet no life has yet been uncovered
meanwhile we've got decades of listening
for messages from outer space and it's
identified precisely nothing despite
there being billions of stars in our
galaxy and thousands of nearby
exoplanets
might we be alone after all and more
special than we imagine do we search for
aliens because we're scared to be on our
own in the immensity of the universe or
is it just a matter of time before
aliens come knocking at our door so help
me answer these questions i have a
fantastic
panel of scientists with me today
nick lane is the professor of
evolutionary biochemistry in the
department of genetics evolution and
environment at the university college
london and his cutting edge research
explores the deepest questions around
life itself and he is the author of four
acclaimed books um on evolutionary
biochemistry and which have sold more
than 150 000 copies worldwide
and thanks for joining us nick um i'm
also delighted to introduce abby loeb he
is professor of science at the
university at harvard university and he
works primarily in astrophysics and
cosmology and was the longest serving
chair of harvard's department of
astronomy for almost a whole decade and
uh he is now a new york times
best-selling author and finally i'm i'm
delighted to introduce one of my own
personal heroes i'm damian justin bell
bernal and she has long been a pioneer
of astronomy she completely
revolutionized the field when she
discovered pulsars as a graduate student
and
science as a whole particularly across
the uk has really benefited from her
leadership for many decades the question
is
are we alone in the universe and more
special than we imagine and i'm going to
invite each of our panelists um to very
briefly summarize their answer to that
question and so we are going to uh start
off
with uh nick lane nick um are we alone
in the universe
i doubt very much that we're alone but
uh
we haven't found anything yet and i
think there's two ways of going about it
we can look out and try to find evidence
of life out in the universe or we can
look in
not at ourselves but at life on earth
and try to understand the principles
that govern uh the emergence of life
is it something probable in a particular
set of planetary conditions is it
something we would expect to see
repeated elsewhere what are the rules
that govern the emergence of life and i
think that's
perhaps the most exciting question a
biologist can ask and it's my own way as
a biologist of asking these questions
about life elsewhere in the universe so
very briefly i i my own feeling is the
kind of conditions that give rise to
life on earth requires little more than
a wet rocky planet
and and there are plenty of those around
plenty of exoplanets around
um
you're generating the right kind of
conditions in my view in hydrothermal
vents but lots of people would disagree
with that
but
that would imply that life is easy and
should start almost anywhere on any wet
rocky planet or moon and potentially in
several different places in our own
solar system um but then there's a
strange trajectory of life on earth
which is to say bacteria have remained
bacteria they're still they're
identifiable in the fossil record
four billion years ago
and and today we still see essentially
the same things all complex life that we
know about so plants and animals but
also things like amoeba
they share a common ancestor that was
already a remarkably complex cell we're
thinking 10 000 times bigger perhaps
than
a bacterial cell lots of moving parts
inside massive genomes in comparison um
there was a serious shift in the scale
of life which happened about two billion
years ago for reasons that nobody
scientists can't agree among ourselves
about what what the driving force for
that
uh my own view on this is that it
required um it required very intimate
relationships between cell cells getting
within cells for reasons to do with
energetics uh which i can talk about if
people are interested later on but uh
it's basically unlikely i would say it
happened once here that doesn't mean to
say it couldn't have happened hundreds
or thousands of times it doesn't mean to
say it's not going to happen elsewhere
but i i think it frames the question in
a slightly
more
um tight way uh i think these same
conditions would apply elsewhere not
only but but largely just as a matter of
probability that life is likely to be
carbon-based it's likely to require
water it's likely um
to be cellular these these kind of
considerations and for those reasons my
own thought is that complex life is is
not going to be nearly as common as
bacteria
and even when we got to complex life if
you just wind the clock back a million
years or so there weren't any humans
around then the planet was full of
enormously complex life wonderful
complex life but not not anything that
would become a space-faring civilization
so we have to also question whether
there is any dynamic in evolutionary
biology that necessarily gives rise to
the level of complexity that we are my
own feeling is there isn't uh that there
isn't a driving force towards that
obviously it doesn't preclude it but i
don't think we should necessarily assume
it's out there
thank you very much uh professor nick
claim um let's move on to professor abby
loeb uh are we alone in the universe and
more special than we imagine abby
well i would think that it's arrogant of
us to think that we are special and
unique i mean it's true that if you go
back in history aristotle argued that we
are at the center of the world and this
view was accepted for a thousand years
because it flattered the egos of many
people and i can sort of understand that
because when i watched my daughters when
they were young at home
they tended to think that the world
centers on them and that they are
special and unique and the smartest but
once we took them to the kindergarten
they had a psychological shock to see
other kids and realize that they are not
the smartest kid on the block
and the
humanity is pretty much going the same
path uh and obviously if i were to ask
my daughters in the first day
whether they want to be at the
kindergarten or at home they would
prefer to stay at home and maintain
their illusion so one way to keep
thinking that we are alone and unique
and special is not to look through
telescopes just like the philosophers
during the days of galileo preferred not
to look through his telescope and
maintain the view that
the world centers on us
and that didn't change reality reality
doesn't really care what whether we
ignore it the earth continued to move
around the sun so we might have
neighbors irrespective of whether we
look through our windows
and the i think scientific knowledge is
always good and it should be based on
evidence
and of course the way to figure out is
to invest funds in the search
and that involves two types of searches
rather than have a prejudice
you can search for
primitive life microbial life which
formed very early on earth as soon as it
cooled and so it's very likely to exist
on
tens of billions of planets in
the milky way alone
and the reason i say that is because we
know that roughly half plus or minus a
quarter of all the sun-like stars
uh based on the kepler satellite data
have
an earth-sized planet roughly at the
same separation as the earth is from the
sun so not only we're not at the center
of the universe also what we find in our
backyard the earth sun system
are quite common you find it everywhere
and
therefore we are not privileged this is
called the copernican principle um and
so we should uh search for primitive
life it's very likely to be out there
and most of the stars formed billions of
years before the sun
and that that means that if you roll the
dice
uh
tens of billions of times and most of
the time you do it billions of years
before us
they probably existed and
they predated us and they perhaps sent
equipment into space in the form of
voyager that we sent or new horizons and
we might find this equipment in space uh
i call it space archaeology if we search
for the relics of dead civilizations
that are not around anymore
thanks very much uh professorilo and uh
finally uh professor dane justin bell
bonnell uh is there life on is there
alien life out there justin are we
more special than we can imagine
20 or maybe 30 years ago there was a
survey in britain of churchgoers
they were asked the question would you
or your faith be disturbed if life in
outer space was discovered
and the answers were remarkably
consistent
and remarkably interesting
the answer was no i would not be but
i'd be worried about other members of my
congregation
so i i think this isn't actually the
issue it's sometimes built up to be
i think if and when we do find life
elsewhere
i think people will take it in their
stride it's likely to be at a
considerable distance and contact would
be minimal so we're not about to be
invaded or anything like that
the scene is also changing very fast
as of about now we know of about 40
sorry 4 000 stars that have planets
around them
and that number is doubling every two
years
so the number of known exoplanets is
growing very very fast
at the moment that 4000 that's about the
same as the number of stars we can see
in the night sky with the naked eye
unless you live in a city center so the
next time you see a nice starry sky say
to yourself there's as many planets up
there as there are stars
we've
got some criteria i think about what's
desirable
it's helpful to have a large moon
stabilizes the spin axis
it's helpful to have a magnetic field to
screen out particles from a flaring sun
you want a sun that doesn't flare too
much and certainly doesn't explode or
anything like that
you want to be well away from any
massive black hole in the center of the
galaxy
well away from any star that would
explode
and a circular planetary orbit is
helpful
but even with those criteria there are
zillions of possible sites in the
universe
so i think patience is called for in
this game
so now we move on to our debate you've
heard the opening pictures there and um
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas